so my greatest memories I've been
collecting are from the 70s I'll say
that every two weeks there was this new
music coming out so every Monday in my
dad was just because record store and
you know it's it's a habit I still have
to do this day we just go there and you
look you say there's this this this this
this this this this this this this this
is this this that for this now in the
70s to get a 45 record it was about 60
cents so my dad and I use just totally
been shop that's how I required my music
in various forms of research for my
father's show rewards for good grades or
it just being Wednesday hey let's go
right to something that's how we bind it